it's
really interesting to talk about these
wild ideas about the future whether it's
aliens whether it's ai
with brilliant people like yourself
who are focused on very particular tools
of signs we have today
to solve very particular like rigorous
scientific questions
and it's almost like putting on this
wild dreamy hat like
some percent of the time and say like
what are like what would alien
civilizations look like what would alien
trash look like well what would our own
civilization that sends out
trillions of ai systems out there like
hal 9 000
but 10 000 out there what would that
look like and you're right any one
prediction
is probably going to be horrendously
wrong but there's something about
creating these kind of wild predictions
that kind of opens up no there's a huge
magnetism to it
right and some of some of it um
you know i mean some of the jules verne
novels did a phenomenal job predicting
the future right
uh that that actually was a great
example of what you're talking about
like allowing your imagination to
run free i mean i just hope
i just hope there there's dragons that's
it's like
i love dragons yeah dragons are the best
but see the cool thing about science
fiction and these kinds of conversations
it
doesn't just predict the future i think
some of these things
will create the future pla planting the
idea
this will help the humans are amazing
like fake it till you make it
humans are really good at uh taking an
idea that seems impossible at the time
and for one any one individual human
that idea
is like a it's like planting a seed yes
that eventually materializes itself it's
weird it's weird
like science fiction can create science
drive some of it it drives the science i
agree with you and uh
and i think in this regard you know
i i'm like a sucker for for sci-fi
um it's it's all i listen to like now
when i
when i run and um and some of it is
completely implausible
right and it's like i don't care it's
it's so
it's uh it's both entertaining
and uh you know it's just like it's
imagination you know about the black
clouds book i think this by fred hoyle
this is like
this has great connections with sort of
a lot of the advancements that are
happening in nlp
um right now right with you know
transformer models and so on but uh you
know it's this black cloud shows up
in in the solar system and then you know
people try to
send radio and then it learns to talk
back at you
wow you know so anyway we don't have to
talk at all about it but it's just
it's something worth checking out that
on the alien front with the
black cloud to me and then exactly in
the llp front
and also just explainability of ai it's
fascinating just a very question
stephen wolfram looked at this with the
movie arrival it's like what would be
the common language
that we would discover the the reason
that's really interesting to me is we
have aliens
here on earth japanese japanese is the
obvious answer
japanese yeah that would be the common
uh maybe it would be music actually
uh that's more likely it wouldn't be a
language it would be art
that they would communicate but you know
i i do believe that we have
um with uh stephen wolfram on this a
little bit that to me
computation like programs we write that
you know that they're kind of
intelligent creatures
and i feel like we haven't found the
common language to talk with them
like our little creations that are
artificial are not born with the
whatever that innate thing that
produces language with us and like
coming up with mechanisms for
communicating with them
uh is uh is an effort that feels
like it will produce some incredible
discoveries you can even think of
if you think that math is discovered
mathematics in itself
is a kind of um oh yeah it's an innate
construction
of of the world we live in um i think we
are
you know a part of the way there because
pre-1950 right
computers were were human beings that
would carry out
arithmetic right and i think it was ulam
um who worked in los alamos at
the at the time like towards the end of
the second world war wrote something
about how
you know in the future right computers
will not be
just arithmetic tool but will be truly
an interactive
you know thing with which you could do
experiments right at the time the notion
of doing an experiment
not like in the lab with some beakers
but
an experiment on a computer designing an
experiment
on a numerical experiment was
a new one that's like you know 70
of what i do is i design com you know i
write
code terrible code to be uh clear like
but you know i write code that creates
an experiment which is a which is a
simulation
so in that sense i think we're beginning
to interact with the computer in a way
that you're
saying not as just a you know fancy
calculator
not as just a you know call and request
type of thing but but you know something
that can generate
uh generate insights that are otherwise
completely unattainable right they're
unattainable by doing
analytical mathematics yeah and there's
uh like
with the alpha fold two we're now trying
we're now starting to crack
open biology so being able to simulate
at first
trivial biological systems and hopefully
down the line complex biological systems
right my hope is to be able to simulate
psychology
psychological like sociological systems
like humans
have you know um a large part of my work
at
mit was on on autonomous vehicles
and the fascinating thing to me was
about pedestrians
human pedestrians interacting with
autonomous vehicles and simulating those
systems without murdering humans
would be very useful but nevertheless is
exceptionally difficult
yeah i would say so when is my mustang
going to drive itself
right it's i'm not even joking it looks
like
yeah yeah i it turns out it's much
difficult
it's much more difficult than we
imagined yeah and and i suppose that's
the kind of
the uh progress of science is
just like you know going to mars
it's probably going to turn out to be
way more difficult than we imagined
sending out probes to investigate planet
nine at the edge of our solar system
might turn out to be way more difficult
than we imagined but we do it anyway
yeah and we figure it out in the end
it's actually more of a great i mean
going
sending humans to mars is way more
complicated than huma
sending humans to the moon you'd think
just like naively
yeah both are in space who cares like
if you go there why don't you go there
um you know
just life support is uh is an extremely
expensive thing yeah there's
a bunch of extra challenges but i
disagree with you i would be one of the
early people to go i used to think not
yeah i used to think i'd be one of the
first maybe million to go once you have
a little bit of a society
i think i'm upgrading myself to the
first like 10 000.
you